and uh let's just jump right into the
first story and this is going to be an
uh just a kind of a
segue into what i perceive as like
ultimate trump derangement syndrome
so it's actually very simple here's the
story from the hill trump nominated a
second time for nobel peace prize
it's got 25 594 shares this is
incredible
a member of the swedish parliament on
friday nominated president trump
and the governments of kosovo and serbia
for the 2021 nobel peace prize
over economic cooperation and trade
talks and i can only imagine
that with this new bahrain announcement
bahrain israel there's going to be some
more nominations
and trump maybe could win this so great
great i wonder what the what the
reaction's been from the oh
and the nobel peace prize the trump
nomination shows that peace had its
chance
and blew it and they actually show the
note the nobel prize and they've
scribbled out
alfred nobel's face wow that's so crazy
man
so kim yes i'm i'm sure you've heard a
little bit about these historic
agreements
and you know uh it just to me
you know i i could probably i could
personally go on for a million years
about
foreign policy because that's like one
of the most important things to me it's
one of the reasons why
i actually am not i've been more
supportive of trump he's pulling our
troops out of the middle east
but i think uh well the first question i
have is you're obviously a big fan of
trump
huge fan yes i am big supporter
you wanna i don't even know where to
begin with this this is like the
ultimate trump derangement syndrome
yeah to to call for ending the nobel
peace prize simply because trump's been
nominated for doing something good
right right well obviously you know
right now like you said it's tds
but at the same time here we are coming
up on elections right
and the last thing they want is a good
story to come out about trump
um this is like them trying to abolish
the electoral college right
yeah i mean it's just like whatever they
can do to make sure
he doesn't look good they're going to
try to push it out but
you know this is what i love about
president trump you know these are the
things that he talked about that he was
going to accomplish
and so here you have all these countries
actually acknowledging
how great he is with the trade war and
they can't handle it
they can't handle it they they will not
allow this this particular
this week has been insane in terms of
dropping
bombs to just smear and drag trump at a
time
when these deals are coming out i'm
looking at the news and i'm like
is trump's campaign strategy to do good
things as president
and the democrats campaign strategy is
to just keep complaining about trump
that's exactly what it looks like yeah
exactly what it looks like
and you know not to talk about myself in
my race but
my opponent my opponent does the same
thing he talks about president trump he
talks about me
but he has no platform this is like what
democrats do
you know and it's unfortunate because i
don't know how they still have people
that vote for them
you know and then you know if you're
talking about
you know just how racist america is and
how you want it to change
how do you then vote for the party with
no platform to change it
i don't get it i've looked at a bit of
what like say biden
wants and i've looked at a lot of what
many democrats offer
and some of them seem to be there's a
lot of democrats who have you know
obviously like middle of the roads
approvable opinions
but then you'll see things in the media
like this
but you'll also see you know a good
example for
joe biden in my opinion when he was
asked if he was for reallocating funds
away from the police
he said yes absolutely but then later he
comes out and says no we want more
more funds to go to different police
programs and i understand there's a
nuance there
right right you can you can reallocate
funds from some areas and then fund
other areas
but it really does seem like the
question being asked of him was in line
with the idea of defunding the police
right it felt to me like he's just gonna
say what he has to say
oh yeah that's that's what they're great
at that's what kamala harris says also
you know and it's sad because again it's
just pandering
right but the fact that people still
can't see this so many years later
makes no sense to me so joe biden's what
almost 50 years
yeah you know what has he done
to even match what he's talking about
today now we hear so much how he cares
about black lives
really this is this is what really
really bothers me right now
is that donald trump has just nailed
these peace agreements he's being
nominated for a peace prize and joe
biden comes from obama's legacy of
increasing wars
uh i mean and i'm not here to rag on
obama i think it's silly to be like well
what about obama
what about george w bush what about bill
clinton right we have all these past
presidents starting wars
in my opinion uh i don't want to say
it's a waste because i don't want to be
disrespectful to the to the troops who
need this funding for their safety and
security
but i don't like the idea that we we we
spend so much of our time and energy
on these foreign conflicts you had eight
years
of an obama biden administration where
were there peace agreements with
with with israel and any other country
instead it was
conflict it was libya it was more wars
it was
you know a civil war in yemen drone
strikes so so anyway i
i i'm going to go on a tangent when it
comes to foreign policy stuff but here's
the main point
yes people are actually going to vote
for joe biden when he has a legacy of
war
and donald trump is staring you in the
face with these peace agreements and
withdrawing our troops
yeah that that is the crux of of the
arrangement syndrome
and i think i don't i don't know if the
if it's you know correlation or
causation from the democratic party to
the democratic voter
like do you think the democrats do
things if the voter says to do it or do
you think the voters just vote for
whatever the
democrat says to vote for you know i
think it's both
i think it's both right so right now you
see what's trendy right black lives
matter
everyone's so upset it's it's both right
is there an agenda
behind it is that the dnc pushing it i
don't know right i'm not gonna sit here
and talk about conspiracy theories
but you know the fact that it comes up
every four years is a little suspicious
you know um but yeah i think the dnc
controls some of it
and then there's those who get paid um
to also throw some fire
um so i know in baltimore city we have a
ton of non-profits
you wouldn't know it by looking at
baltimore city that we have a ton of
nonprofits to help with the vacant homes
and the homelessness
you wouldn't know that but a lot of
people are getting paid a lot of money
uh for these non-profits and of course
they're going to continue voting for
those democrats because they're the ones
giving them the grant money
you know so we all we see where they
leverage that urban struggle
to get that federal funding and they do
it annually so i think it's both sides
you are you are preaching to the choir
man i used to do fundraising for
nonprofits
and the last run i had as a fundraising
director was for a homeless shelter
that was lying to people to make money
and
they they were telling everyone they
were at capacity and these kids are
suffering and they had nobody in their
shelters
because the kids didn't want to go there
it's a much deeper problem and so what i
ended up seeing is
you yeah they had their donors and they
made
a decent amount i'm not gonna act like
the biggest nonprofit in the world
but instead of actually solving the
problem they just
set up shelters and then went to people
and said
oh man all these kids there's no space
for them how are we going to get them
beds
you have to give us money instead of
offering up mental health services or a
real solution to the problem
i felt like their goal was just to
perpetuate
this this uh mirage yeah this this fake
image of what was really needed
they never did anything yeah i'm not i
don't want to let's start to say
necessarily say where it is but of
course it was a major urban
you know democrat controlled city with
serious issues that they didn't care to
actually deal with
and so for me i i voted for obama in
2008
and uh you know hope and change and the
wars
things like that and then i was it was
just the same
to me a lot of the same stuff because
because again for me
i think i was coming into the political
realm
with like the iraq war that's when i was
like a teenager and i'm watching the
stuff and i'm hearing all this music
like system of it down and i'm like yeah
the war's bad
i started looking into it and i'm like
yeah the war is bad yeah and the media
lied to us
and then they just kind of kept going
with it for 20 years
yeah so i don't know i don't i don't
know what we do to change people's minds
so that they stop voting for the same
thing you know what i mean no i don't
know i
i mean i i voted for obama in 2008
myself um
i was so excited i was like wow you know
that overcoming story
is a black president we can no longer
say
the white man's keeping us down here he
comes
family structure great husband great dad
done it's over we don't have that excuse
anymore he gets in there and what does
he have
a ton of excuses and i'm like this is
not why i voted for you yeah
this is not i thought hope change i
thought all of these things were now
gonna be addressed
um so i was thoroughly disappointed in
2009 i changed into a republican wow
really
yeah that quickly i was really upset
i mean but obama he he he was
inaugurated with january 20th 2009
right at what point in in 2009 where did
you realize
it was hold on there was a he went to
some kind of meeting he had with jesse
jackson and
they were talking about the fact that it
was so
tough to be black in america and i'm
watching this and i'm like
you're literally the president of the
united states of america
how is this even you can't even have
this conversation yeah you know
and it just kept continuing and i was
just i was over it
i was over it um i didn't tell my
parents right away because i didn't want
them to be upset
you know usually if you're black you're
a democrat and i get that but
you know after talking to my dad about
it he was actually more conservative and
understood
wow why why is that i mean i i defer to
you i have no idea uh
they say that uh the black community
just votes democrat
yeah so you know for me it was when
you're getting the news filtered in
through your parents right they're
always telling you you know it's
democrats are the ones that are socially
liberal they're the ones that are going
to help you
you know if you're in a situation
they're the ones that are going to bail
you out of it
um and i guess you know maybe in their
generation
maybe that's what they saw and that's
what they believed and so it just
continued down
um but then when you really look at it
and you start that critical thinking for
yourself
i mean i talk about all the time you
know most black families grow up in the
church
that's a conservative value system right
there
you know and you look back at like the
civil rights leaders
they were all at church on sunday you
know they talked about god often
and so you know i think over the years
we just you know walked away from that
and but then we continue still being
democrats you know
and thinking that's the way to be so i
was reading an article and they said
uh it was it was it was a it was around
the time kanye had done something
and there were a bunch of polls coming
out showing that black voter support for
trump was very very high
there were a series of polls earlier
this year like 30 percent which was like
unheard of
and there was an article i was reading
and i think it may have been i don't
want to misquote somebody about i'm
thinking james carville or somebody
they said the key to the black vote is
the church
and that to me it sounds right based on
the things i've seen on tv
right where they have this trope of like
you know the the churches and the and
you know the politics around it
but then i thought to myself i'm like
yeah but the democrats are like the
opposite of
christian conservative values like they
don't agree with a lot of what the
church says in fact they
they're they're they kind of insulted a
lot yeah not necessarily the politicians
i don't
i'm not putting i just mean like the
culture right you'll you'll go on to
social media you'll and and what do they
allow they allow a lot of very
anti-christian
anti-church kind of rhetoric but other
religions sometimes
you know they pretty much get a pass so
i look at pop culture and i'm like that
doesn't make sense to me why why why is
that i think we're right on the cusp
we're right there like this is why we
got to change things right now
it is grandma and great grandma holding
on
into that church lifestyle right you're
still going to grandma's house for
sunday dinner
you know you might not have gotten
church that day but you're showing up
for sunday dinner right
um so we're i think we're at that point
where it's like what do we do
we got to make this decision to kind of
come back and understand the importance
of family values and family structure or
just spending time with your family
and so i think i think it's honestly you
can right now
i believe in two weeks we're meeting
with 30 pastors in the baltimore city
area and that's unheard
of for any republican um but apparently
my opponent when he was there
uh in his previous terms 1987-1996
he went to these same pastors asking for
favors
you know asking for their support and he
went in didn't do
anything walked out right uh congressman
cummings comes in
and now he's coming back and they're
like whoa buddy we remember you
you know we were the pastor at that time
and so now they're willing to talk to
us um and i think if we can get to his
congregations
uh that we can do it i mean my opponent
his big voting bloc was
senior black women wow and they are the
ones in the church
so you think they're going to vote for
you instead
i'm holding out hope here tim you're
hoping for them
i i think i think we can talk to them
the fact that they're even having the
conversation
is blowing my mind that's exciting yeah
yeah how does it how does it end up you
know
i come from chicago you're in baltimore
that you have decades after decades of
your dec
after decades of the exact same things
being said
it almost feels like uh there's a lot of
people who
they vote because it's kind of like a
passive thing
and they don't actually know or care
yeah i want
how do you how do you change this well i
mean you're doing it you're changing it
so
what are you doing yeah so uh this is
what's interesting so you know i had the
special election right this is when i
went up
after congressman coming's passed away i
actually ran before
you know against now quiescent fumey uh
he's now the incumbent because of the
special election anyways
uh what we found out through that
special election because we had the
mail-in ballots
right the coronavirus lockdown number
one we couldn't go face to face and talk
to people
right interesting number two the senior
black woman isn't on facebook
looking for my virtual conversations
right so i didn't reach harley anyone
but we did have a nine point swing
so all of my votes in the city i have
howard county baltimore county and
baltimore city
um 42 of my votes in the city what came
from democrats and independents
so i'm like wait a minute wait a minute
somebody wants to change and i haven't
even talked to them
right um so with that you know
now you fast forward we saw with the
mail-in ballots oh
somehow 80 000 uh ballots went
undelivered
yes i saw that how did that happen right
and then so we're like okay so we lost
we got it
you know i know the general primary is
coming up i'm feeling pretty confident
about it i said but now we got to go
figure out what happened with these
ballots and who didn't get them
so we spent a lot of time in west
baltimore in the areas where you saw me
take my campaign at
and so in those areas you know we're
talking people they're like hey did you
get your ballot you know did you get
anything and
people were like no i didn't get
anything we talked to them
and there was two things here one people
move around a lot
right they didn't have an address where
those those ballots came
and then two the people living in the
worst living conditions
weren't registered to vote so i
now our team is out there seven days a
week registering voters we were doing
two days a week at first now with seven
days a week
and then i other my field team is out
there seven days a week knocking doors
and doing the sign waving and all that
so
thank goodness i have a team that is
working so hard on this
you know it's it's crazy but that is the
issue we've got people living in the
worst conditions
not even taking part in the process and
so we're out there explaining it to them
and i have to say
uh in the past i think it's a month and
a half we've registered over 200 voters
right um from what i know only 17
percent
have registered as democrats oh they're
working
you're right showing everybody we are
we're registering everybody so you know
independence came up a lot and
republicans now
because they're sitting there talking to
my team about what's the difference
and this is what i was talking about in
my rnc convention speech
i go in my team goes in and we talk to
people we're like
what do we have to do to get you to vote
for a republican and they're like
you're the first republican i've ever
met wow hi my name is kim yeah
so cool yeah so you know it's like if
we're not offering the option
i can't complain i can't say hey you
know what are you doing i can't talk to
you like that
yeah i have to say i apologize i am so
sorry the party hasn't been out here
to offer you an option why
i think i just asked a simple question
where's the gop
so you know when i when i said i wanted
to run
um i was told and i quote
jesus christ could not win that race
do not do it we are not going to exhaust
our our donors
on you and so i said all right
um i'm not jesus christ i know he's
way better than me but i'm going to give
it a shot and
i'm going to just try to make my own
money and if you're not going to help me
that's fine
because i've gotten pretty far in life
without you know a ton of help
and i think i can do it and now you have
i think one of the most viral political
ads ever probably
thank you i wish i could take all the
credit for it it's not a
i'm not i'm not trying to compliment
it's a fact
so this is august 17th democrats don't
want you to see this
they're scared that i'm exposing what
life is like in democrat-run cities
that's why i'm running for congress
because all black lives matter baltimore
baltimore matters
and black people don't have to vote
democrat help us win and of course
it's you walking through the streets of
baltimore 12 million views
162 900 retweets
317 000 likes that's amazing
i think i think you struck a chord with
a lot of people because i'll tell you
what
um that red i i know i mentioned it a
lot i'm from chicago
but i watched that and i was like yup i
know exactly what you're talking about
and i didn't i didn't grow up in the
black community or anything like that
like you did you have
a you know a kind of different
perspective in that regard but it's the
same thing i see
yeah i grew up in a city that was just
democrats all day every day nothing else
no matter what
and then it felt like things only ever
got worse for us or we only ever got
screwed over
you have people would just it's the
craziest thing when i was told to go
vote
i was told just do democrat all the way
down i was like who am i supposed to
vote for just vote for all the ds
i'm like okay and that was me when i was
like 18 or 19 or something wow
but that's that's i don't know why
i guess you you you brought it up
earlier this idea that if you're in
trouble the democrats are the ones that
help you out
yeah but maybe that's not really the
solution maybe the solution is
hard work responsibility absolutely
family values
i i had good parents and so they
instilled in me good work ethic
and uh ambition and that allowed me to
succeed and i look at a lot of other
people i grew up with who did not do so
well
who had this mentality of it's not your
fault it's other people's fault
right so then they don't actually change
their circumstance
but maybe that's the goal right yeah
i've
i i want to be careful about how i
phrased this but
some people maybe just i should just say
it the democrats created dependency
yes i i say that all the time so you can
say it yes
that's exactly what's happened and you
know what's crazy about it
i'll talk to some people you know i
still show up and talk to people in the
streets myself
and this one guy came up to me the other
day and said you're not gonna
cut off my my food stamps are you he's
like you're not gonna cut off my
disability are you
and i was like no sir but
i just i just want to ask you if you
were presented
with a career opportunity where even if
you
you know with your disability you could
do that career and you made great money
and you had health benefits and dental
would you then
say you know what i'm going to take that
over what i have right now
and he said of course and i said okay so
you know is it really
is the question then me cutting off
these things or
offering you something extremely
an opportunity beneficial yeah and so i
think people are starting to understand
and this is why i talk about my platform
all the time
it is the opportunity piece you know
when you go in west baltimore
there is nowhere to work we are a food
desert as they call it right
there's no grocery store around for
miles but it's a city that's weird
it is yeah so um it's an interesting
situation it's
you almost feel like you're not in
america especially not in 2020
i think that's like that's actually like
a a really easy
i don't want to call it a policy
position necessarily but something to
look for in terms of solving the problem
creating opportunities for people who
instead of just receiving benefits could
find
a way to generate revenue and help
bolster their community
yeah but i guess is there is there
anything specific about uh
your you know your district that you've
seen
is there anything specific you would
call out for the representatives as to
what they should have done or things
that they're not doing
or that you want to do yeah so i i tried
to keep it very simple for them in the
very beginning you know
by just showing the trash piling up
i'm like look you know you are getting
all of this funding right
uh baltimore city annually 1.1 billion
dollars
since 2015 when we had the riots
you're getting all this money but for
some reason in these neighborhoods
where they've got low income they
probably don't vote
they don't donate to your campaign
they're just being completely neglected
for some reason you can't seem to pick
up the trash
and this is what's interesting you know
i i haven't been in the area that long
but i talk to people and they say you
know the trash
got picked up and twice a week when i
paid less
in taxes and i said well so now you pay
more
for the trash to pile up right there
down the street you know
rats are running everywhere rats in the
middle of the day you know and this is
what kills me
remember when uh president trump was
attacked by saying
rat infested yup yeah there was a young
lady in my i was interviewing her
i posted a video right and she said it's
a rat
infestation he literally tweeted
verbatim what she said
and then all of a sudden he's attacking
baltimore the best part is
she herself was black yeah but it was
racist to say those things
and no god go ahead good no i
i was just you know when everything came
out and this was in july 2019
i i was in shock i didn't say anything
for two days like i'm getting phone
calls like are you gonna do an interview
you can do it
i was in shock because i was like
nothing that's coming out is actually
true
so now what i know my voice isn't big
enough i know cnn
msnbc all those stations refused to have
me on right
so i can't correct the record wow thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you